[Musique]
à quelques jours du départ du grand raid
les agents de l'office national des
forêts termine les derniers aménagements
sur ces pistes que vont emprunter les
coureurs de la diagonale des fous
près de 70% du tracé du grand raid sont
des sentiers gérée par ses agents
assurent par exemple on dégage les
sentiers sont des voies de communication
que nous gérons à une petite échelle
comme une commune route avec ces mêmes
ces mêmes préoccupations les éboulements
l'eau la qualité de la chaussée et la
fréquentation de la fréquentation et la
végétation
le département propriétaire des forêts
publiques financent la gestion courante
des sentiers chaque année 9 millions
d'euros sont investis dont 6 millions
pour leur entretien et 3 millions pour
la prise en charge des ouvriers en
insertion et donc chaque année le
département met les moyens pour que
lohan f
les ouvriers puissent travailler et
remettre en état ses sentiers c'est un
travail permanent nécessaire mais nous
sommes heureux de le faire parce que la
réunion c'est la réunion des eaux
c'est la réunion tentiez ou à la voix il
faut emprunter les sentiers faisons ces
travaux le département et louhannaise
préserve et valorise les 987 km de
sentiers aménagés à la réunion des
pistes forestières empruntée chaque
année par plus de 5 millions de
randonneurs
[Musique]